nevada's vaccine incentive program
receiving some backlash
after the first round of winners were
chosen people have been reaching out to
us all day with concerns
about being entered in the drawing and
considered as a winner
joe muller live in our newsroom on this
friday evening with some of those
concerns
hey there brian yeah representative from
immunized nevada says if you got your
shot you were automatically entered into
the drawing now peoples are saying
they can't find their name on the
website and are worried that they aren't
actually getting their shot not the
winnings
[Music]
every thursday through august more
winners will be announced in the vax
nevada days program
thursday a north las vegas woman won 250
thousand dollars
and i had my vaccine done months ago
wendy pajor watched the first
announcement unfold she logged into the
immunized nevada website to make sure
the state had her records
i looked at my information on nevada web
iv and it says there are no results for
me pay her is one of many wondering if
they are in the running for the
thousands of dollars of prize money
i would like to know that everyone is
included that has received the vaccine
you know is is that what they're going
off of the nevada web i see
website others are wondering how the
winners are selected
according to the vax nevada day's
website winners are chosen at random by
a company called
igt other states have used it too the
website also shows people are
automatically enrolled in the
raffle using the immunized nevada
records but records must be submitted to
the state
our concern is individuals who are out
of state but are residents
and are out of state not by choice but
because of pressing matters
don salmon says he wants to know why
people who are vaccinated in other
states but live in nevada cannot be
eligible
he got his vaccine in west virginia
where he travels too often for families
i'm retired marine corps 20 years active
duty seven of it are listed
enlisted and 13 as an officer sure i'd
like to get
qualified i think i should be because
i'm a resident and have been for 11
years
as is my wife i reached out to the
governor's office and immunized nevada
to find out how people may be able to
get their records to the state we have
yet to hear back on that
also if you were wondering about the man
yesterday who interrupted the
raffle he was escorted out and he was
not
arrested reporting the newsroom joe
mohler 8 news now